[Applause]
keep going keep going don't stop don't
you stop clap give your hands
pleased happy Tuesday everyone what a
mildly attractive
group so he thought his doctor was a
jerk until his heart no longer works
worked comedian and actor Bob Odenkirk
has been kicking around show business
for over 30 years he started as a writer
on SNL he was really funny on the
underrated Ben Stiller show he
co-created the brilliant sketch comedy
Mr Show and now most people know him as
the CD attorney Saul Goodman on Better
Call Saul Good Things good thing there's
no lawyer that sleazy in real life am I
right he also does a lot of charity work
for the underprivileged
I knew the audience would not know who
David Cross
is but I left it in there anyway because
I don't care a few years ago Odin Kirk
had a heart attack and almost died while
filming the final season of his series
true Better Call Saul became better call
911 it's a fate I wouldn't wish on any
actors unless they try to bring back
According to
Jim Odin Kirk survived thank goodness
and recently he went on a podcast and
looked back on his heart attack saying
this near-death experience could have
been prevented if he had only listened
to his doctor so why didn't he listen my
doctor was a conservative he got
crankier and crankier the older he got I
hated this side of him that I only
learned over time he said you need to
start taking statins right now and I
said well I don't know I don't have
heart disease in my family he goes just
take them and and I had a heart attack
and I think the first doctor was right
the cranky conservative Jack was right
because he was a God good doctor his
political point of view doesn't have
anything to do with his ability to judge
your health and your health choices and
needs well that's well said that's why I
never question my liberal doctor when he
gives me a
mamogram so it appears Bob's an honest
guy pudos to him he didn't need to say
this in public but he wanted everybody
to know the tough lesson he learned I'm
sure all his Showbiz friends deserted
him like he was Jerry Nadler at a nudist
colony I know think about that but
America needs more of that these days
well that enhan some brilliant people
like me to point it out we need to start
seeing each other as human beings again
not not just Pawns of two opposing
political parties our lives are more
important than some dumb agenda and
someone should tell that to those hairy
heers at the
view we're people not talking points
except cat she's more of a warning
label but what if Odin Kirk had a doctor
with a much different worldview like I
don't know maybe
this the upside uh she can check your
prostate without her
hands I know but imagine if he had a
far-left doctor who had told him not to
do anything to prevent heart disease
because you know there are too many
humans on the planet already because
he's an old white guy who doesn't have
the common decency to identify as an old
white woman because politics Will indeed
matter if say you have a woke Doctor
Who's only concerned with Equity someone
who lets you die untreated to raise the
rates of cancer among your group
identity to match those of another quote
marginalized group that's the logic
sorry you're going to die bill but enjoy
your last few months knowing you
contributed to an equitable societ
Society here's an envelope for BLM when
you make out your
will you can imagine how bad things
would get if all those jobs you rely on
to make your life better were filled
with woke Knuckleheads the woke mechanic
would say instead of an oil change I
converted your car to solar power it
only works when it's sunny out that'll
be 80 grand or how about a woke police
officer can I see some ID we add reports
there are people over the age of 18 at
this drag show or how about the woke
teacher wait those are
everywhere and how is that working out
our students are it's as if education is
replacing knowledge with grievance and
team locker rooms with I'll show you
mine if you show me yours now let's look
at it from the opposite perspective how
many wers have refused good advice
because the experts had the wrong
politics sure I could have changed my
oil when that check engine light came on
4 months ago if I supported poisoning
Mother Earth with fossil fuels also can
you give me a ride
home you know doc I'm against the use of
all petroleum products including
Plastics so you'll need you you'll need
to do that prostate exam on me wearing a
renewable wool
glove wasting all that water just
because my home's on fire now I'm really
glad I glued myself to that fire
hydrant sure I could describe the man
who beat and robbed me but you'd
probably run straight to the cops let's
just say he's a really dark skinned
white
male if all this sounds crazy consider
that we now have doctors in America
cutting off little boys genitals because
they play with Barbies and somebody told
them they're actually girls thank God
these doctors weren't around when I was
a kid I went trick-or-treating as a kid
dressed like Dorothy Hamill three years
in a
row I got 27 scker bars and three gold
medals doctors are capable of being as
blinkered and unethical as anybody else
plus they can't
[Music]
dance for years now we've heard the
refrain that's between me and my doctor
I've said it many times myself when I'm
asked what I'm doing at the
gynecologist but even medicine is
getting weird the American Medical
Association is pushing something awful
called Health Equity to fight narratives
grounded in white supremacy evil
narratives that favor meritocracy and
individualism meaning they prefer to
treat you as one person belonging to a
group that oppresses rather than a
person with chest pain but maybe you
deserve to be sick that mole is
malignant but so are you so why would
you allow your medical decisions to be
swayed by any outside consideration
you'd never say that's between me my
doctor and the Department of Motor
Vehicles or would you if you'd rather
have a heart attack than listen to a
republican maybe the problem isn't the
Republicans sure you went completely
blind now but at least you didn't let Dr
Rand Paul an opthalmologist tell you
what to do the moral of the story listen
to the person who's telling you a hard
truth even if you don't like him and if
you insist on being woke all the time
take it up with your
anesthesiologist period let's welcome
tonight's
guests like Stevie Wonder he also
doesn't get to see his kids actor writer
and comedian Jamie
lissow she's tougher on China than a
loose bull former State Department
spokeswoman and founder of Polaris
National Security Morgan
Ortez throw a bread stick in any Olive
Garden in America and you'll hit 10 guys
who look just like him Fox News
contributor Tom
shaloo and she's got more fake hair than
a trumpy bear New York Times
best-selling author and Fox News
contributor cat
tip Jamie in The Green Room you said
your doctor keeps pushing assisted
suicide on
you any reason why yeah and he wants me
to assist myself which is so weird I
actually have a very L my surgeon is
like really liberal he's been wearing a
mask like even before Co
[Laughter]
um it took a minute but then they were
right there with me yeah yeah um I
really do like my I trust my doctor and
he really is liberal as some as many
doctors are he told me to he said like
to stop traveling for comedy and I said
oh I heard that like maybe like being on
planes is it's like bad for your health
and he was no it's because you've been
coming here for years you've never said
anything
funny okay um I don't know I heard the
thing about the the anesthesiologist
when you said that at the end that
always makes me think of other people
people have very important jobs and I'm
glad Odin Kirk admitted this right that
was really I think you're right that
it's really cool they ad people have
more important you know you got to
listen to people that are smarter than
us and have like anesthesiologist that's
like a important job like I never I
could never have done that cuz like when
I worked at Arby's MH sometimes I would
I would give someone like a little bit
extra yeah and
um with anesthesiology you can't do that
no you
can't anymore that was pretty good thank
you I think that's you should probably
end there yeah I think it's yeah end on
a high note okay so to speak Tommy yeah
um youve you know as an actor you
probably played a doctor sometimes in a
panel van outside of a woman's College
um what do you make of this should you
judge somebody on their politics When
selecting a doctor well it's interesting
because you like I say like you said
like Jamie said you give the guy credit
because it seems like he's learning yeah
know and that was a a revelation for him
oh wait a minute this guy's a republican
but maybe he's the guy who was going to
give me the good advice actually I don't
like his advice I don't like statens
there's too many people on him so just
uh you know I I I don't think there's
any reason to think that that's why he
haded heart attack you know maybe it was
a different thing that caused his heart
attack like the injection he got three
months before he had the heart attack
the experimental
injection yeah maybe
maybe you really hate that vaccine don't
you uh but I I don't know anybody who is
concern I know a lot of conservatives I
know a lot of liberals I don't know any
conservatives who would not trust their
doctor because they were liberal like we
can't go through our lives if we're only
using conservatives if I want someone to
direct my show how am I going to find a
republican director there's not that
many of them you know what I mean uh
you'll never be able to find them
because they won't admit it yeah exactly
but the the the thing about the doctors
it's like bipartisan you know I think
they they both failed you know the
doctors on the right and doctors on the
left most of them failed during coid uh
but the ones who did it's interesting
doctors during coid a lot of the not
every so few of them were able to Buck
the system but those who were were
usually the conservatives and the ones
on the left they actually were forced
into being conservatives like a doctor
there's many doctors that you can see
the and people even left-wing activists
people like Naomi wolf they were kind of
pushed now they're called right-wing
activists because they were skeptical of
the co policy so it's funny it wasn't
it's not really a bipartisan thing but
they almost made it one m M that is so
true you know Morgan I think this comes
from the original ideology of
progressivism which is politics is
always personal yeah so that's why they
can always say I need to have politics
at a sporting event I need to have
politics uh at on in Academia I need to
have politics at the at the at the
Thanksgiving table and it has to be in
the doctor's office what say you lady in
red I actually that was the first Dance
at My Wedding to that song Lady in Red
yeah cuz I we red wedding dress who sang
that don't do this to me again was it
the Rolling Stones I don't remember all
right I know you know I never know the
names of these bands yes so I you know
it's interesting that it's even news
Odin Kirk talked about this on a podcast
like this is such a revelation that a
conservative could be good at something
so it's like I don't even know why
that's news and he felt the need to talk
about it in podcast but I think what
sucks is especially because of Co like
you said politics has entered things you
know every profession places that it
didn't used to be you look like I had a
baby a few days after the election and I
went to uh a Women's Center at the
hospital to birth now I would go into
the birthing center for people who are
giving birth you know whatever
ridiculous name they're using now and I
mean I don't think I'm going to have any
more kids but if I go into a hospital
and they call me a birthing person
instead of the mom or a woman it's not
going to end well for whoever is
delivering for me
yeah cat I'm going to go out on a limb
and say you probably gotten some bad
advice from
doctors well I I don't know I like I'm a
unique individual MH with my own very
unique medical
history so it's like I don't think it's
a part of a group that wouldn't work I
mean when they're like whenever they're
like okay let's whatever medications
you're on I'm like here we
go um but I I think it's great that he
actually said this because I think he's
a guy who kind of does this a lot I
remember when the summer of 2020 when
all these TV shows and episodes were
getting scrubbed from streaming services
from all these different shows when it
happened to his he was like I disagree
with that happening I think that that's
a really important thing to do and I
obviously don't have a choice because as
a Libertarian if I only saw doctors that
agreed with me that that just wouldn't
be a thing I don't think like Gary
Johnson could have done my surgery no no
no but Rand Paul's a Libertarian and
he's an opthalmologist that's an eye
doctor Jamie Oh I thought it was someone
who thinks really positively about
stuff
that was good that's funny yeah so all
right well I think we settled
nothing okay hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else